[Musique]
Je pense que je l'utilise depuis environ
2014, alors c'est sorti, un de mes amis m'en a
donné un, ah, maman, va
essayer ça, puis je l'essaie, c'était
tellement
sympa qu'il cuisine  rapide je l'utilise pour cuisiner
des haricots parce que je l'aime tellement qu'il
ne noircit pas votre casserole lorsque vous l'
utilisez vous vous sentez à l'aise vous n'avez
même pas besoin d'étirer même les odeurs l'
odeur qu'il fait ressortir vous aimez votre cookie
et  un peu de cannelle
avons-nous oui d'accord est-ce qu'il est à toi
ça économise ton carburant et puis ça
te donne une flamme plus forte tout
devient bleu tu sais je le garde à
côté et quand mon gaz est fini je ne m'en
soucie même pas parfois je  je suis resté sans essence
pendant une semaine entière, vous savez, alors je me suis
impliqué et j'ai demandé à
d'autres femmes de la zone rurale
de les aider à s'impliquer, à faire des
affaires et à ne pas continuer à utiliser du
bois de chauffage qui dégage de la fumée avec tout
le dioxyde de carbone,
tout ce que vous pouvez
éliminer, vous pouvez voir
le meilleur, c'est plus rapide
que le
gaz [Musique], nous avons actuellement beaucoup de
maladies cardiovasculaires respiratoires non transmissibles
qui sont imputables à la
pollution de l'air, nous l'appelons donc pollution de l'air domestique.
Passer à une feuille comme la
feuille B qui est renouvelable va
nous aider à réduire les pertes liées à ces
problèmes de santé tout en protégeant notre
environnement des émissions de carbone
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
lorsque vous vérifiez en Afrique, vous remarquez que
les gens  en fait, cuisinez avec du bois de chauffage depuis
le début, vous le savez et à partir de là, il
y a des maladies qui
tuent les femmes et l'une d'entre elles
est arrivée au visionnaire um
Co où il a perdu sa grand-mère alors qu'il
était jeune parce qu'elle cuisinait avec
du bois de chauffage et vous savez quand  il a grandi,
ils ont appris que c'était le coût,
quelle est la solution à
cette façon de cuisiner, vous savez, à l'exception de la
source de cuisson propre qui est
fabriquée à partir de déchets de biomasse,
les produits finaux totalement propres sont l'oxygène, donc c'est sans danger pour la
santé humaine  et l'
environnement [Musique]
[Musique]
va